[Música]
[Aplausos]
conocen esa sensación
de no saber cómo llegar a final de mes
o esa de cuando suena el teléfono y es
el banco el que está llamando porque el
saldo de la tarjeta se venció
o esa
de cuando encuentran un billete en un
pantalón que tenían tiempo que no usaban
o esade cuando te pagan por hacerlo
queda más sobre todo cuando entregas
valor a otros y eso se ve reflejado en
tu cuenta bancaria
yo las conozco a todas
mi historia con el dinero no es
precisamente una historia idílica
se parece más a una historia de amor y
dolor
a mis 17 años con una madre recién
divorciada y que afrontaba una
enfermedad difícil me tocó trabajar para
sostener mi casa
mis amigas fueron las deudas
y este fue mi primer encuentro con una
de las emociones más profundas del ser
humano
la depresión
dormía sedada
porque la falta de dinero me quitaba
literalmente la paz y el sueño
decidí emprender porque para mí ese era
el camino a la libertad financiera
en algunos casos fue exitoso y en otros
no tantas
de alguna manera terminé siendo asesor
financiero
pero no llegué aquí porque lo haya hecho
todo bien
el mío ha sido un camino de errores y
aciertos
acertadas o no mis decisiones con
respecto al dinero me enseñaron que los
números hablan acerca de nuestros
hábitos
y de las cosas a las que les damos la
cara y aquellas que no queremos ver
aprendí que las finanzas son más que
números son emociones y aprender a
gestionarlas nos facilita la mitad del
camino
entendí que el dinero no es malo de
hecho ningún instrumento financiero es
malo
son sólo esos instrumentos medios de
intercambio facilitadores de sueños
y que digan lo contrario aquellos que a
través de una hipoteca obtuvieron un
hogar
aprendí que hay dos relaciones que nos
van a acompañar durante toda la vida
la relación con nosotros mismos y con el
dinero más nos vale cuidarlas a ambas
en 2011
la university college london la open
university y el bebé se la viu que
realizaron una encuesta en el reino
unido a más de 100 mil personas llamada
the big money test
esta encuesta pretendía demostrar que
nuestra relación con el dinero hablaba
de la relación con nosotros mismos
y definió cuatro tipologías de personas
según la relación con el dinero
si usted cree que el dinero es
importante porque lo hace ser exitoso y
poderoso
quizás usted sea un gastador de estatus
si por el contrario usted es de los que
prefiere ahorrar porque uno nunca sabe
si ocurre una emergencia
entonces usted podría hacer un protector
seguro
si usted demuestra amor a otros
comprando cosas para ellos usted quizá
sea un indulgente generoso
esta es una característica muy presente
en las mujeres sobre todo en aquellas
que son madres
alguien aquí cree que tener suficiente
dinero le permitirá alcanzar lo que
quiera
a nosotros nos llaman los amantes de la
independencia
sea cual fuere nuestro perfil con el
dinero estos comportamientos están
asociados a emociones como la ira la
vergüenza
o el miedo
es por ello que hoy quiero compartir con
ustedes cuatro claves que nos permitirán
tener una mejor relación con el dinero
la primera de ellas es la mentalidad con
la que afrontamos esta relación
y con esto me refiero a la forma en la
que percibimos el dinero
entonces entendamos qué es el dinero
el dinero es un objeto
un objeto que hemos decidido
utilizar para intercambiar algo que
valoramos
si hubiésemos escogido el destornillador
en vez del dinero como medio de
intercambio hoy estaríamos hablando de
nuestra relación con el destornillador y
no con el dinero
a lo que voy con esto es que lo
importante en la percepción del dinero
no es el objeto en sí sino el poder que
transferimos a ese objeto
y este poder viene cargado de un
componente emocional importante
emociones
que terminan haciéndonos creer que el
dinero es bueno o malo
un ejemplo de ello es la llamada deuda
buena y deuda mala
no existe cosa como tal cuando hablamos
de deuda buena o deuda mala
estamos hablando de juicios de valor no
de conceptos reales
estos juicios vienen del miedo
ya sea a repetir experiencias pasadas
o el miedo por desconocimiento
y esa viene a ser nuestra segunda clave
el conocimiento
por un lado tenemos el conocimiento
técnico que es importante a la hora de
tomar decisiones
debemos entender cómo hacer un
presupuesto
debemos saber leer el extracto de la
tarjeta de crédito y conocer cuál es la
diferencia que hay entre un bono y una
acción
pero conocer esto
no nos exime de cometer errores
un elemento que es importante en cuanto
al conocimiento es el conocimiento
acerca de nosotros mismos
de cuáles son esos activos que nos
permiten generar ingresos
y no me refiero activos físicos me
refiero a esas habilidades y a esos
talentos que nos permiten entregar valor
debemos entender cuáles son nuestras
prioridades en la vida y qué es lo que
está siendo importante para nosotros en
este momento
y debemos conocer cuál es nuestra
tolerancia al riesgo
todos estos elementos nos permitirán
tomar decisiones acertadas o no
nuestras emociones
podría llevarnos a cometer errores
un ejemplo de ello es cuando salen estas
ofertas en algunas tiendas
salimos corriendo y si vemos algo que
nos parece atractivo compramos y listo
en algunos casos nos vamos a arrepentir
de esa compra
en otros quizás disfrutemos del producto
durante un tiempo y luego lo desechamos
qué tal si suspendemos por un tiempo la
decisión de compra y hacemos de este un
proceso un poco más consciente
entendamos cuál es el valor que aporta
ese objeto en nuestras vidas
su vida útil la calidad del producto
observemos nuestra vida de forma
consciente sin el producto
y si después de un tiempo decidimos que
aún queremos comprarlo pues hagamos el
gasto
de esta manera nos daremos cuenta de que
la decisión fue nuestra y no un impulso
emocional
todos queremos resultados financieros
positivos pero cuántos estamos
dispuestos a pagar el precio por
alcanzar esos resultados
esta es nuestra cuarta clave
la generación de hábitos financieros
saludables es el precio a pagar por
alcanzar esos resultados
ahora ustedes se preguntarán cuáles son
esos hábitos que debo tener para tener
resultados positivos
yo los invito a que se hagan una mejor
pregunta
qué es lo que está haciendo importante
en mi vida en este momento y cuál es mi
prioridad
si lo importante es mi seguridad y la de
los míos tener pólizas de seguro o un
fondo de emergencia podría ser un hábito
saludable
si lo que me importa es la generación de
ingresos y el futuro de mi familia
entonces invertir en educación para
mejorar esos activos con los que entrego
valor podría ser una opción
mentalidad
conocimiento decisiones y hábitos cuatro
elementos inherentes a nuestro ser no a
lo externo y que nos permitirá diseñar
la relación que queremos con el dinero
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]